that's a great question I think one
thing that I want to really encourage
people to do is to take a learning
approach so in other words you want to
create feedback mechanisms with your
customers so you can get quick ideas
about what's working what's not working
I do a lot of work with media companies
and I've been because of sort of my
background I worked with a lot of
communications companies back in the
mid-90s and I was the one sort of task
with sort of predicting the future based
on broadband and wireless and broadband
wireless and all this stuff and a lot of
things became quite obvious to me early
on about the impact of this to
newspapers and magazines and I used to
talk to these groups and you know they
would applaud and then ignore me but the
the thing that became apparent to me
then was that once I got used to reading
online the idea of a magazine became
difficult for me because of you know
what i would call at that point you know
asst alien see you know things might
have changed i mean i was a magazine
journalist originally wrote for magazine
so it was it was kind of a huge epiphany
for me that it the immediacy of the
online world is so compelling because as
things change then it changes what's
important and the you know so when you
talk about this idea of brainstorming I
think it's really important that you
instead of you know separating yourself
from your customers and and thinking
about your you know whatever you think
is important is to do the exact opposite
which is to go where your customers are
and watch them and live with them if you
can and and really it's about
understanding how they're solving their
problems because that's where you're
going to get a much better idea about
what their habits are because if you
introduce a product that works against
habits it's a very very hard sell
because you're going to get all that
built up inertia and I think that that
in the future what we're going to be
doing to be more effective is really you
know watching first spending a lot of
time with our customers solving that
problem as best we can and then
reintroducing that to the customer in
that natural environment and then see
how well we've done
you